we begin this morning with a coronavirus
hot spot under a new threat from
nature this time it's a hurricane
hurricane is
could make landfall as early as today
somewhere along florida's east coast
the storm is 80 miles southeast of
nassau the bahamas now florida is the
epicenter of the coronavirus pandemic at
this time with record numbers of new
cases
and death set this week the storm is now
complicating efforts to contain the
virus
manuel bajorkas is in riviera beach
florida manny good morning
good morning jeff practically the entire
east coast of florida
is bracing for the impacts the potential
impacts from hurricane isaiah
anything from strong winds to flooding
rains to
storm surge it is especially a concern
here along the coast of palm beach
county
and up north along the i-95 corridor
where the hurricane could make landfall
overnight this entire
area is under a hurricane warning
florida's governor has declared a state
of emergency
he's urging residents to have seven days
worth of food water and medicine ready
but also
facial coverings and hand sanitizer as
this potential disaster
is merging with the covet 19 crisis here
it's important that you start to include
personal protection equipment in those
packets in those hurricane preparedness
kits today
state-run testing sites in some areas
were closed ahead of the storm
until next week hampering efforts to
track the virus
some miami-dade county hurricane
shelters are on standby
with the potential to provide separate
quarters for those who are currently
infected
governor ron desantis said the state has
a supply of personal protective gear
at the ready as well as generators for
nursing homes at risk of losing power
right now on hand they have 20 million
mass
22 million gloves 10 million gowns 1.6
million face shields
two hundred seventy thousand coveralls
and twenty thousand
thermometers already is
battered parts of the caribbean
including the bahamas
and some of the islands that were
devastated by hurricane dorian last year
it hammered puerto rico and parts of the
dominican republic too
as it travels north the governors of
north carolina and virginia
have already declared states of
emergency with north carolina ordering
evacuations from at least
one barrier island a hurricane during a
pandemic is double trouble
but the state has been carefully
preparing for this scenario
so that we can do our best to keep
people safe from the weather as well as
the virus
the concern is not just along the coast
but also
parts inland which could also see strong
winds and
flooding rains the important message
here in florida from officials this
morning and also along
the eastern seaboard is that as we run
out of time to prepare for the storm
people
should very soon be in the place where
they intend to ride it out
dana all right manny thank you